poverty and disease are major problems
in emerging markets poverty disease are
major problems in Africa that major
problems in India the major problems in
the solfege third world countries lack
of access to education is a major
challenge in this communities with
better education better information we
can go a long way in addressing poverty
and disease in emerging markets but
unfortunately currently not enough money
is being spent in the efforts to address
poverty and disease in Africa so address
poverty disease in the generality of
emerging markets why is this the case
the major problem is that developed
countries see the world is hiv/aids
poverty as African problems as energy
matic problems they don't realize that
all of our challenges are interconnected
if we don't address poverty in Africa
there's nowhere we can have Africans
impress the climate change agenda if we
don't address HIV AIDS in Africa HIV is
in emerging markets there is no way
those communities are going to be part
of the agenda to serve the oceans they
are agenda to certain environment in
other words we must understand the need
to address these global challenges in an
interconnected manner must understand
interdependence of communities because
if Africa is not on board on the climate
change agenda if the poor countries are
not on board on saving the oceans the
options cannot be saved the climate
change agenda cannot be adopted so what
we need to do is to understand that HIV
is poverty nuclear weapons climate
change the options all these global
challenges are interconnected what we
need is a global approach to poverty you
cannot be a rich nation when there's a
poor nation of Haiti next door you
cannot be a poor European nation when
the starvation in the for when
poverty in Zimbabwe in other words the
sustainability of the cloth requires all
of us developed and developing nations
to work together in attempting to
address the profit challenge in
addressing the education challenge in
addressing a challenge around diseases
because if we do not do that the poverty
of Sudan will be the poverty of America
permit of Liberia the poverty of
Zimbabwe would define the poverty of
Germany of Switzerland no nation can
ever claim 12 a claim to success when
the levels of poverty dismal within the
same globe so given this new approach of
interdependency of nations
interconnectedness of global challenges
will be able to then have a much more
sustainable answer to the issues of
poverty to the issues of disease and
people take a vested interest approach
in wiping out the disease like malaria
tobacco seas and also reducing the
incidences of hiv/aids in Africa and
elsewhere this is what we need to do and
also we have saved education is a key
driver in addressing poverty and disease
hence the provision of access to
education the provision of information
the leveraging of the ICT revolution is
a unique opportunity by which developing
nations can reach out to poor nations so
that the poor nations with the
information and education can address
their problems around poverty their
problems from hiv/aids their problems
are on economic development there is no
opportunity here using science and
technology to leapfrog from the 19th
century where African economies are on
21st century technology is a big
equalizer but that technology must be
shared
it must be technology transfer from the
north to the south they must be
technology transfer from the west to the
east so that we empower and develop
ourselves and in doing so by the way is
not charity when ghana is successful
when the zimbabwe is successful when
Liberian successful when Sudan is
successful that would be a key driver
for global success so we are saying we
must redefine the meaning of national
success we must talk about regional
success we must talk about global
success because we are going to sink or
swim together as a globe this is the new
way forward around poverty and disease